hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Bigfoot that is the
Bigfoot now there's a game that I
ordinarily play with friends for some
reason I feel like I have to talk in a
hush voice because yes this actually is
my night vision camera and what that
means is I'm going to be alone in the
woods which is good because my friends
won't die if I die but if I die I'm the
only one that dies and my friend will
never know what happened to me but if
I'm successful I will have hunted the
Bigfoot it is kind of creepy because
this room actually is Pitch Black let me
turn off the night vision for a second
that's how dark it is
you can see the sliver of the doorway
and just a shadow of my face and that's
it so I have an infrared sensor uh
picking me up and then I have infrared
light on my face and that is about it
everything else is pitch black I should
play horror games like this which is
pretty much his I think I might actually
we have Winter Park now welcome to
Winter Park your next luxury winter
getaway enjoy the snow-covered landscape
this winter by visiting your friends and
family from the stalactite covered caves
to the frozen lakes and rivers Winter
Park is a tranquil vacation spot you've
been searching for
is it now certainly the Bigfoot is not
afoot okay I can set the amount of
Health that Bigfoot has the amount of
damage and the amount of loot
considering I'm by myself I kind of want
to increase the loot because that's
going to make it a little bit easier for
me
weapons I don't have anything there Rick
Jessica Thomas William Bigfoot
um honestly the running speed might be
good Vitality explosives damage blind
duration reload speed
both weirdly enough I think it's going
to be more beneficial to get running
speed there are no vehicles in this and
I'm going to be on my own so I'm going
to play as Jessica and B on my own a
Bigfoot otherwise I feel I really feel
like I have to be kind of hushed about
this
it is strange do I expect to win yes
will I win I don't know I've done this
before by myself but I'm not 100 sure
it's gonna go well for me
recent reports show that three popular
influencers have recently disappeared at
Winter Park video blogger Daniel his
model girlfriend Alexa and their
photographer friend Ethan
had all gone camping together at the
park the three went missing after a
planned photo shoot in the woods just
two days after their arrival rescue
teams have been searching endlessly for
them to no avail fans of the famous
couple have been arranging millions of
online broadcasts asking for help be
careful of Winter Park it's easy to get
lost in the sea of snow
yes it is
now there's gonna this is gonna be weird
because at night it actually will get
super dark I have not played a horror
game in Pitch blackness in a very long
time if ever this is going to be a novel
experience for me since I'm by myself I
actually do have to be really smart
about the um
the traps and whatnot but I'm on my own
already
okay 100 found dead I gotta get moving
okay
uh GPS censor oh yeah you can actually
stick that into Bigfoot and that'll be
helpful
trap that's the first trap
I think Bigfoot definitely attacks every
night but I'm not 100 sure
uh if he attacks the first night it may
be afterwards he starts attacking but I
don't know good thing the all the ammo
is mine I don't have a shotgun yet
but I'll get one eventually I don't know
if we even managed to find all this
stuff when we were playing together Baba
Bob Wade Sean and I I don't think we
look through the drawers okay
flare gun
layers camera
map
storage
and that's it
okay
oh wait no it's not it meet
and bullets are in the freezer keep them
cold oh God it's dark
I guess we're starting up pretty early
oh night one
okay I don't know if he comes out on the
first night I'm gonna have a big problem
if he comes out on the first night I
don't think he does
but just in case
I'm gonna start going I have my traps I
can trap lay a trap Susie comes charging
at me should get him give me time to run
I only have the one trap which kind of
sucks
is that trap how's that
oh
all right evidence found
I guess
oh it's dark it's very dark it's very
dark it's very extremely dark
I don't know what I'm doing
oh
what is that what is that
holy hell I hate this
oh okay all right I see some kind of
structure over here
probably some more goodies
maybe a place to hold up
that's good more 762 ammo
empty storage just a bunch of oh 7460
yellow
I think that's yellow yeah yellow seven
four six zero I wish I had something to
write that down with I think I do well
that's handy
I'm not I'm not screwing around here I'm
just gonna trap this and I'll come get
it afterwards because if he comes up
here I'm gonna be very upset
that's green I don't think that's right
seven four six zero
nah oh oh that was it oh my God okay
that was a better
AVM
is this a better rifle
I thought that said that it was yellow
it looked it looked yellow maybe because
it was yellow light that's probably why
oh God
oh good lord
great googly moogly all right seems to
be doing okay
check that I checked that I didn't check
this bag
um all the drawers
oh no
okay all right
um terrible terrible okay I think I now
have checked all the storage
uh I don't know if you can hide from
Bigfoot I don't even know if that's a
thing I mean they have lights maybe that
is a thing
where you would actually be able to hide
from him
like if you turned out all the lights
and just stayed up oh my God
that is not okay
that's so unbelievably not okay I don't
think he comes out on the first night
I don't think he comes out on the first
night I think I'm fine so I just gotta
make my way into the bottom floor
I'm gonna just in case
just in case
oh
nothing
oh my God stop
don't do that
oh this is awful I do not like being
alone
I hate being alone here but I'm gonna
get okay day no yes I can't tell
it might be starting to be day now
which would be helpful this is nice
because all of the the windows are
boarded up here and there's really only
one point of entry and there's a
secondary place there so theoretically
this would be a good place to Hole up in
the middle of the night seems like I'm
okay for now and I've got plenty of ammo
and I got a new gun which is good that
is very good I think
okay so if I go across the lake here
if I just yeah okay
I don't think I can go back up that but
that was fun a good Escape if I need to
that's another reason why that place
would be good to hold up is because I
can get out of there quick
but I gotta find more supplies what I
have is not going to be enough as much
as I would like it to be it's not going
to be enough I need a lot more the only
way to get a lot more
is to keep running around but I gotta
make it back there before nightfall that
is going to be my hole that's going to
be my hole and it's made for me and I
don't know if you can get in with the
doors and all that but at the very least
it's a start better than being on the
open it's too bad that my uh my lights
in my room don't go with the day night
cycle that's so that could be like an
ambitious project of mine is to hook up
my lights so that whenever I'm in game
whatever the day night cycle of the game
I'm playing it does that to the lights
and it would automatically go to night
vision mode
if
it needed to oh
I don't need more meat and I hesitate to
make more noise
hmm
don't mind me don't mind me don't mind
me
anything up here nah
oh
oh you can go up it
I don't know how that works
but uh that's handy
okay good to know
not many supplies though kind of coming
up short here because I think by the
next night he is going to start coming
at me and the last thing you want is
Bigfoot coming at you there's got to be
there's usually things at the end of the
road if you look at the map
the end of the road here there's usually
things
I think I can make this full circuit
before it's time for Sundown I just
gotta find like some explosives or
something hello
ah Grille
meat good
nothing there
nothing there oh what is that
that's concerning but that noise over
here maybe that'll draw him away or
maybe it'll drop him towards me I don't
know
her and we'll draw her towards me I
don't know if Bigfoot is big guy or big
girl there's no resurrecting myself if I
die by the way
if I die I'm dead period so my objective
is to not die but I've only got one trap
I've got just a single trap which is not
enough
oh my God there's so many of these zip
lines but there's not enough actual
Supply
I went the wrong way if I actually
wanted stuff I think that the big town
is right there
because I think this is the same map as
the one we played before but it's just
winter which means that the conditions
are harsher and probably supplies are
more spare
sparse but maybe I can get something
there's a cave up here or something
oh my God okay
there's usually some goodies in a cave
but also there might be about an old
Bigfoot in a cave
also I'll have no idea if it's actually
day or night outside so I gotta hurry
to use Burger wrappers
ah
aha
aha shotgun that's good that's probably
good
why is it all got to be the primary
weapon
at least I got an assortment so if I
press I can't hot swap between them
it's just one or the other I wish I
could set it to be my second but might
as well do flare gun second because that
gets him to run away
okay where's the Sun
I don't know what time it is I don't
know why I bothered does my tablet say
nope you know we don't have the
technology for the time so my objective
is if he gets in to the base I just need
to get it in a way that I trap him so
that I can get out and through the zip
line if I'm up and down the zip line
then I should be okay nothing should be
able to get me then I keep doing tab
instead of map
uh nothing
oh God I gotta get back
I gotta get back I think it's sir I
think it's starting to get darker over
there I'm seeing the Aurora Borealis
which usually means that it's almost
time for night uh oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah I gotta go oh my God I went
the wrong way
oh
it's gonna be flares because that's all
I got if I if I if I encounter him or
her
I'm just gonna flare him in the face and
run away and that's what I'm gonna do
all night I'll trap if I have to but the
traps kind of break after one go so I'm
gonna try to avoid
ah it's beautiful
that is gorgeous oh
I guess I should take a picture of that
huh
I guess in this map the lake is frozen
so there is a potential for using it
for what I'm not sure yet I don't think
it's quite oh it's night it's turning
night
okay that's bad at least I got a clear
field of view on the lake
not like he can sneak up on me I just
gotta set up cameras too I have not been
sad what is that
I don't know what that is
I've not been setting up cameras
oh God hey
ow why
oh I forgot that that could be a thing
who would do that
who would do that
who did that
uh
car battery okay I can eventually make a
bomb out of that I think all right you
know what that sucked I don't know if
Bigfoot's ever gonna come down to this
extreme of a location but if I set up a
camera here
at least give me some kind of the you
know
this Edge will be covered oh no it's
dark
oh no
foreign
oh no
I could have made it back to that house
oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh it's so
dark oh it's so dark
oh it's so dark
oh my God it is dark I should have put
the camera at this Crossroad here
because at least that would have been
able to capture a lot of the area huh
when some lose some
win some lose them
mom
oh that's okay
Knight two officially well
I felt like that already happened
oh my God
oh my God I'm gonna cut in
why what happened wait oh my God
oh my God
oh my God
no
no
that alert came from the camera I just
placed at the crossroads up there
it might have been nothing
I don't know if it's a motion sensor or
just
only Bigfoot sensor
says could have been an animal or
something but nothing seems to be
charging at me
stop that stop it sounds like someone's
hitting something with a rock or a piece
of wood
maybe that's Bigfoot setting up a trap I
don't know
there should be a big Village up here
oh hi dear hi dear
yep oh stop
stop
big stop did the light just turn off
over here did I see a figure in the
window oh God hate hate
hate
oh my God oh my God oh my God yeah run
run holy crap he had like a stick he was
hitting
oh my God what do I do holy [ __ ] I don't
have enough of those
oh my God
oh he's coming back he's coming back
he's got me back
oh man I
Rubble
in trouble
I'm gonna try to trap
okay uh I'm screwed
um I'm screwed
oh my God what are you doing what are
you doing did you just jump up what
happened
oh
what is happening
oh God oh God
oh God
[Music]
I gotcha
oh boy oh boy that's not good
oh boy oh boy get oh God no
oh ow oh wow oh wow
okay
foreign
[Music]
I healed
oh he's coming back
okay uh flare don't miss
I think he had enough of me
no okay he still wants more
oh boy I don't know I've got
one flare left
okay let's try the AVM
[Music]
oh
I can't I'm I'm stuck I'm just
what do I do
oh God oh God oh God
oh he's so quick he's so quick oh
what do I do I can't oh I can Vault over
that okay I see well that's interesting
didn't know about that
I was trying to do that it wouldn't let
me Vault over it before
is it over
please tell me it's over
please tell me it's over I don't know
why but it seemed like the shotgun
didn't do nearly as much as the rifle
did even though a rifle should clearly
at at close range not do as much as a
shotgun
but whatever
[Music]
uh please don't I did some damage to him
I mean he's gonna heal it up but you
know I did do some damage let's not
dismiss that I fought and I fought well
which is uh better than I've usually
done
got to be more goodies around wow okay
this is a bad sign
just gonna ignore that
just gonna ignore that
that's completely fine la la la la just
stepping in the blood oh sweetie
[Music]
oh nothing
nothing
ransacked
with a whole lot of nothing
drone battery I have not used the Drone
I suppose I could Scout where he is but
um
I really need to just Scout some
supplies
interesting
interesting
that would be here
very interesting
I'm Laden with oh my God why did I do
that
oh yes please more flares
that's good can you shoot the fire
extinguishers or stuff is there like
explosive barrels is there like already
traps in the environment that I can use
probably uh I've got so much ammo but
what I really don't want to have to do
is to resort to shooting him to kill him
I would love to make a bomb why is there
blood and help oh God
no
a lot of supplies stuff for me
anything I can actually use no fine
fine then
I got a trap
finally a trap holy hell an actual trap
I can't believe it first one I've found
a lot of good is gonna do me but
whatever
I guess people don't come out into these
woods with just traps falling out of
their pockets
even though that would be the smart
thing to do
hapless hapeless hopeless
hopeless okay I think that's the one
that I was in and the front door is now
busted off of it I don't think I
actually looted it though not the bottom
floor anyway
foreign
GPS sensor oh
a lot of GPS sensors but not a lot to do
with them I don't plan on getting that
close to the big guy
oh my God okay I do need a first aid kit
though
oh I don't like that I'm bugging out
because what I want to do is I want to
get back to that other house because it
was right next to a zip line very useful
extremely useful so if I can make my way
and just run around I should be able to
use up all of these lovely bullets that
I have and actually be able to make a
dent which I have made a dent I want to
say that I've made a dent but that's
about all I've done
I'm gonna put another camera down at
this Junction
can I climb that ladder that'll be very
useful
can I
damn you go put it right here
Wham
oh
not sure why I care
evidence found Bigfoot I think the
Bigfoot wounds across my body might be
evidence of the Bigfoot
holy hell
okay well I guess I'll put my camera
this way then
got coverage there
okay
zip line let's get back to the blaze
that day cycle was way too fast I'm
gonna be in the upstairs and I've got
another trap and
that's it I should have taken the zip
line
how do I get up here oh my
oh what is that is that a bridge is that
a ramp
oh please
how about I do this right here so I can
see what's coming up the back way oh
that was not what I intended
is that it
is that a plane
you doing a supply drop
can I get a supply drop was I up here
before
wait a minute
have I been here
is this an isolated Mountaintop
that's pretty cool I'm right by the the
town but it's right down there so that's
interesting
okay so it's night three right now
weirdly enough I've got a little bit of
a he's watching I'm sure he is so I'm
gonna actually launch my drone do some
knife flying here
yeah
night vision God I wish this had night
vision oh my vision's getting better
okay I would like to find the Bigfoot my
camera at the base of the mountain
hasn't tripped yet that's the building
that I wanted to get to
but I can't see Bigfoot anywhere
oh there's Bigfoot okay camera four
he's by camera four and he's he's coming
somewhere where's Camera four
must be the second to last camera that I
put down so over here somewhere
oh oh God oh God oh God
always coming for me isn't he oh no he's
coming for me okay let's set her down
okay it's fine
uh
oh my God
oh my God
oh where oh my god oh he's coming oh
he's coming
oh boy goodbye
huh
well that uh good thing he can't take
the zip line right
holy [ __ ] if I see a Bigfoot barreling
down on the zip line I'm gonna be very
upset man Knight's got to be over by now
and it would take him some time to get
down to where I am
oh God
I didn't see him
I didn't there was no trigger of my
camera
oh
my God
holy hell
oh my God holy crap
okay
I'm freaking out of here man
oh my god oh please no no no no no not
fair not fair not fair
[Music]